In 2017, there was a Harvard research
study which looked at the power of
asking questions.
They broke participants up into three
different groups. Group number one was
told to enter into a conversation with a
conversation partner
and just have a regular conversation.
Group two was asked to have a
conversation, but purposefully not ask
many questions. In other words, do the
vast majority of talking but not asking
the other person very often.
Group number three was told the
opposite. They were told to purposefully
ask more questions than the person that
they were talking to.
What they found when they analyzed the
results and surveyed the conversation
partners from every group was that
consistently
group number three was considered the
most liked in terms of a conversation
partner.
And this ties into common wisdom,
especially in professional development
books, where it shares this idea about
be interested
versus interesting. In this video, I'm
going to take that even a step further
because I don't just want you asking a
lot of questions, which would be a huge
win, but to ask better questions. To ask
questions that are driving deeper
engagement, that are making more
interesting conversations.
So, I hope these tips are very valuable
to you. How often in your day do you
interact with somebody by saying, "How's
it going?"
"What's up?"
"What's new?"
These are habits that we have built in
terms of when we see somebody and it's a
quick formality to check in with them,
to go one small step beyond hi.
But the problem is the resulting answer
is often not bad,
pretty good,
things are great, you? That is about as
far as that conversation goes.
But I really like the research Vanessa
Van Edwards did around this. And she has
the suggestion of asking a different
question instead of what's up or how's
it going.
She suggests you ask,
"What's been the highlight of your
week?"
"What's something interesting you're
working on?"
What I love about this is the first
thing, the question
forces the other individual to think of
something positive.
If you're asking somebody what's been
the highlight of their year or the
highlight of their past weekend or the
highlight of their week, instantly in
their head they're searching for the
positives, which is probably going to
make a more delightful conversation.
But the second thing is
you're getting deeper right away in that
conversation.
Because whatever their response is,
that's now giving you more information
to dive deeper into the conversation.
And so it's a really quick entry point
into a great conversation.
This is my challenge to you.
Start asking questions like these. Test
it out when you go out this week, today,
tomorrow. Ask somebody, "What's been the
highlight of your week?" And see what
the response is. A common mistake people
make when they ask questions
is they don't ask open-ended questions.
They simply ask a question that will
result in the person responding yes or
no.
Or in some instances, they lead them
toward the answer.
As an example, if I was having a
conversation with a gentleman named
Brett and I said, "Brett, what are you
most looking forward to this summer?"
That's a great open-ended question. Now,
Brett is thinking about what sorts of
things he might be up to this summer and
it's probably going to result in a
meaningful answer.
But, here's the mistake some people
make. They don't stop at that point and
they keep talking. So, they say, "Brett,
what are you most looking forward to
this summer? You live in Vancouver, so
it's man, such a beautiful place. Are
you I would imagine are you just
sticking around Vancouver?"
That is less likely to result in a great
answer because you've already taken the
step to sort of answer the question on
Brett's behalf.
And what good question askers will do,
question askers, interesting term, what
people who ask questions who know how
this works is they will aim to allow the
other person to do the majority of
talking.
So, I really encourage you, especially
if you're of the personality type where
maybe patience is a tough thing for you
and you want to jump in and help the
other person answer the question,
don't do it. Ask the question, allow
them to think, allow them to respond,
and then ask a great follow-up question
afterwards. You need to do a better job
of listening.
This sounds straightforward. You're in a
one-on-one conversation with somebody,
of course you're listening.
That's sadly not the case for so many
people.
I used to be very guilty of this. I
would be in a conversation and I was
constantly thinking, "What is the next
thing I want to say?"
This happens when we introduce ourselves
at a social event and we're so focused
on saying our own name that we don't
remember the other person's name 10
seconds later.
Listening carefully is something you
have to work on, but it's incredibly
important. And this is going to help you
ask better questions in real-life
conversations
because if we are listening with an
intent to genuinely understand and
showing a sense of curiosity about what
the person is talking about, we have a
chance to get much deeper and explore
new conversational territory that is
much deeper than surface-level.
But if our intent is to simply respond
or to tell our own story,
it gets into this ping-pong match of
very minimal depth in conversations.
So the next time you're talking with
somebody, really make a point of
listening and challenging yourself to
ask follow-up questions to whatever that
person is telling you about. Those who
are the best at asking great questions
often do their research.
This might seem obvious for certain
situations, like if you were hosting a
podcast or you were moderating a panel.
Of course, you want to do some level of
research on your guests so that you ask
really great questions.
But this can even be true for social
situation. You can do a little bit of
research in advance to gain a bit of an
understanding of who's going to be at
that event, what sort of interest they
have, perhaps you do a quick scan of
their social media without being creepy,
and you find that information, and
that's going to allow you to have
conversational entry points that are
more interesting or to remember people's
names and ask them about things that you
remembered seeing.
This is far more likely to result
quickly in better conversations
versus showing up to an event, not doing
any research. And I will say some people
have the ability that they have that
personality where they can walk up to
anyone and just have a great
conversation.
But for the majority of people who don't
have that skill set, doing a little bit
of research in advance to know who's
going to be in the room will help you
and your conversation. One of the most
powerful questions we can ask when we're
in a one-on-one conversation is why.
Because often people will give us a
reason that they're doing something,
something that they're looking forward
to. But by asking that simple question,
why?
It forces them to dig a little bit
deeper and to think,
"Yeah, what is the actual reason I'm
doing this?"
And you'd be surprised when you you ask
that simple question,
instantly the conversations enter a new
threshold because that person starts
sharing more and more information, which
probably taps into the core of what they
care about, the things they're
passionate of, what they hope to
accomplish in the future.
And the more they share that information
with you,
the more that it opens up other
conversational threads or things that
you can talk about, and it
really simply makes for a better
conversation.
So challenge yourself in the
conversations you're in in the coming
weeks,
try to find places where you can ask why
to dive a bit deeper into the
conversation. I hope these tips on
asking better questions resonated with
you and give you some ideas for how you
can implement them in your regular life.
I would love to hear in the comments,
did you try any of these out? What
surprised you? What worked well? Am I
missing any obvious things about what
you should keep in mind when you ask
questions? Let me know in the comments.
As always, thank you for watching this
video. If you have not already done so,
please subscribe to my channel. And if
you want to work with me on a one-on-one
basis and work on your one-on-one
communication skills or future speeches
or maybe you want to launch a podcast,
anything in the realm of communication,
I am here to help guide you and coach
you. I have my Stan Store link in the
bottom. As I mentioned, subscribe to my
channel and check out this video that's
coming up which YouTube is recommending
for you.